i've read somewhere
that the square root of two is your
favorite irrational number
i have no idea where that got started
um is there any truth to it is there
anything in mathematics or numbers that
you find beautiful
oh well there's lots of things in in
math that's
really beautiful um you know i
i used to consider myself really good at
math and these days i consider myself
really bad at math
i never had really had a thing for the
square root of two
but when i was a teenager
there was this book called the the
dictionary of curious and interesting
numbers
which for some reason i
read through and damn near memorized the
whole thing
and i started this weird habit
of when i was like filling out
checks you know or you know paying for
things with credit cards
i would want to make the the receipt add
up to an interesting number
is there some numbers that stuck with
you that just kind of make you feel good
they all have a story and fortunately
i've actually
mostly forgotten all of them
um are they uh so like 42
uh well yeah i mean that one 42 is
pretty magical
and then the irrationals i mean but is
there a square root or two
story in there somewhere well again it's
it's like the only number that has
destroyed a religion
in which way well the the
pathagorians they they believed that all
numbers were perfect and you could
represent anything as as a as a rational
number
and
[Music]
in that in that time period
um the this proof came out that
there was no you know rational fraction
whose value was equal to the square root
of two
and that that means nothing in this
world is perfect not even mathematics
well it it means that your definition of
perfect was imperfect
well then then there's the ghetto and
completeness theorems in the 20th
century that ruined it once again
for everybody yeah although although
although
girdle's theorem um
you know the lesson i take from girdle's
theorem is not that
you know there are things you can't know
which is
fundamentally what it says um
but you know people want black and white
answers
they want true or false
um but if you if you
allow a three-state logic that is
true false or maybe
then then life's good
you